[Music]
Megan Markos departure from suits was
announced on Tuesday just one day after
her engagement to Prince Harry was
confirmed there was a really nice boy
who just the two of us and then I think
I managed to catch the catcher by
surprise as well but the show's creator
Aaron gorsh says the decision to write
the 36 year olds off the show was
actually made over a year ago are you
doing what I think when he realized a
relationship with a royal was serious I
might want to go there in a new
interview with Radio 4 he says we
decided to sort of take a gamble that
these two people were in love and it was
gonna work out he also says it was much
easier to plan on writing her out in
advance than finding out she wanted to
leave the series a last-minute adding
the only way to write a character out
like that would be if they got hit by a
bus or something
the current 7th season of suits will be
Megan's last and she's set to walk down
the aisle and may I'm very excited about
that
[Music]